hey guys I'm Jess module it is the sixth
of March you're watching gamespot news
and i have a bunch of news cut off the
internet presses so stay tuned first up
dragon age inquisition has a new trailer
other in the possibility that it could
even be as good as the original game the
trailer takes you through several ethic
locations from the in-game world before
the crap hits the fan and it's all
monsters and dead bodies the game is
coming to Xbox one and ps4 as well as
just about every other non nintendo
platform check it out and let me know
what you think next up is all the
release dates we got confirmation on the
launches of both watchdogs and dark
souls 2 on PC Dark Souls 2 is all set to
hit your PC's on April 25th while it's
coming to consoles on March 11 the pc
version is set to free to increase
texture resolution and an enhanced frame
rate option as well as refined controls
that will adapt perfectly to mouse and
keyboard pre-ordering on steam will give
you the soundtrack as well as early
access to the black armor weapon set
earn some other goodies as for watch
dogs may 27 is the date you'll want to
keep in mind if you sauce open-world
action game is the one you're holding
out for that's for all console and PC
versions not the wii u version which
will be coming later Ubisoft confirmed
the news officially so that weight after
the announcement of its delay in October
of last year is just about over let me
know which of these games you're more
excited for and why in the comments
killzone shadowfall dev Guerrilla Games
has attempted to clear the air after an
awful lot of controversy over the
shooters native resolution a year again
report found that in multiplayer mode
killzone shadowfall would opt for a 960
x 1080 frame buffer in order to hit 60
FPS according to the dev they've been
using a technique called temporal
reprojection to combine pixels and
motion vectors from multiple low res
frames to reconstruct the image
maybe p so if we're going to be awfully
technical about it that basically means
it's not natively to maybe p after all
which is bothering some fans although
gorilla insists that even though they're
using this technique it's still
generally understood to fit the
definition of native be sure to let me
know who you reckon is right who's wrong
and what you don't care about either in
the comments or on my twitter that is it
for me today but tomorrow I'll have my
top five favorite stories of the week so
if you need to get all caught up that'll
be the place to do it I'll see you soon